how's the grandpa going I think it's
going pretty well I it's quite a lot of
fun to have a little baby around again I
mean I think like most men I'm somewhat
nonplussed let's say by infants it's
easier for me to deal with kids after
they're about once they get mobile a
once I can sort of throw them around a
bit more
then I know what to do with them once I
can play with them but it's really fun
to watch my daughter be a mother she's
really good at it and it's good to have
another young thing in the family and
you know because babies are very they're
kind of like fire you you can't help but
watch them and it's great it's great and
she seems healthy and you know she's
cute as can be
of course babies are sneaky that way but
it's working so yeah I think it's really
going well